[Musique]
c'est un couple d'infirmiers arrivés du
Cameroun l'automne dernier Alain doit
quitter dès le lever du jour
depuis quelques semaines il s'initie au
rigueur de l'hiver saguenéen c'est comme
ça
il fait vraiment fait il a complété son
stage et travaille déjà comme infirmier
à l'hôpital de la baie bonjour ça va
bien est un des 25 infirmiers ou
infirmière recrutés par le scius du
Saguenay Lac Saint-Jean en 2022
et nous étions étonné ébloui de cet
accueil là
bon monsieur Tremblay on va commencer
quelques heures plus tard on retrouve la
conjointe d'Alain qui complète sa
formation au cégep de chez koutimi
de la profession infirmière au Québec on
sait que on entend dire que c'est une
profession qui est tellement valorisée
au Québec une profession qui nourrit
bien son homme Québec annonçait l'an
passé vouloir recruter à l'international
un millier d'infirmières comme Amélie un
investissement de taille 65 millions de
dollars pour les trois prochaines années
chaque recrue reçoit 500 dollars par
semaine pendant la mise à niveau et
s'engage ensuite à travailler trois ans
dans la région où elle a été formée
bonjour monsieur Tremblay je m'appelle
gintfact
aujourd'hui au Cameroun l'offensive de
recrutement du Québec semble bien connu
ça se parle au Cameroun oui ça se parle
même dans les médias tout le temps ça se
parle mais devrait moi ça a été un rêve
pour moi après la formation soins
infirmée je disais toujours à mon père
que j'ai réalisé au Québec l'un des
objectifs est de retenir ces infirmières
en région démographiquement la région au
niveau de la démographie on a un
problème particulièrement dans le haut
du lac donc on a pas le choix de se
tourner vers l'immigration c'est un des
moyens c'est pas l'unique moyen mais
c'est un des moyens de s'en sortir les
infirmières étrangères sont maintenant
essentiels pour maintenir les services
de santé au Saguenay et surtout au Lac
St-Jean
et aussi pour assurer la survie de
plusieurs programmes de soins infirmiers
dans les cégep parce qu'en 2010 on
comptait 1765 inscrits au deck en
sciences infirmières un nombre qui a
baissé à 1475 en 2020 à Chicoutimi les
étudiantes étrangères constituent
maintenant 20 à 30% des étudiants en
sciences infirmières c'est la clientèle
internationale qui nous permet de
continuer de offrir nos programmes
d'avoir assez d'étudiants pour pouvoir
permettre de donner nos cours situation
similaire à l'apocatière dans le bassin
Laurent Daniel Sharon
je viens du Cameroun Marie Jessie
urbatros et je viens de l'île de la
Réunion pour qu'il puisse recevoir son
traitement ce que vous avez des
questions deux chambres parmi une demi
douzaine d'étudiantes de l'étranger qui
contribuent à la relance du programme de
soins infirmiers un programme qui ne
comptait plus que 4 étudiantes en 2018
en 2018 en fait ça a été notre année la
plus difficile quatre étudiantes sont
entrées au programme alors faites les
calculs mathématiques il y a rien de
rentable à garder un programme à quatre
étudiants le nombre d'inscrits est
remonté à une trentaine dont ces
étudiants immigrantes étrangères dont le
cégep a bien besoin mais on mise sur le
fait que si elles viennent étudier dans
la région apprennent à connaître la
région c'est un plan dans la région
s'intègre bien elles vont revenir
travailler dans notre région et
peut-être espère-t-on travailler à
l'hôpital de l'apocatière et contribué à
maintenir des services ici Daniel est
déjà comme préposé dans une résidence
pour personnes âgée et pense demeurer à
l'apocatière après son cours parce que
j'aime beaucoup la région une petite
ville comme l'avocatière c'est tout est
calme tout est beau c'est posé puis
les personnes aussi sont accueillantes
tout le monde est gentil et Marie semble
séduite par l'accueil il y a beaucoup
d'entre elles il y a beaucoup de
solidarité puis on s'est senti tout de
suite accepté les premières semaines ça
a été vraiment
très touchant pour moi sa fille
fréquente déjà l'école de quartier
exactement ce que souhaite toutes les
régions du Québec pour qui l'avenir
passe entre autres par des gens comme
eux ici David Gentile Radio-Canada
l'apocalière